eigentlich sollen wir hier in
Deutschland auch sowas hier bekommen
eine Nationalen Sicherheitsrat wie die
Amis wo alle die wichtig sind für die
nationale Sicherheit mit drin sitzen und
dann unter anderem in besonderen
Gefahrenlagen gemeinsam zügig
Entscheidungen treffen können das
Problem er will dass das Ding zu ihm
kommt ins Kanzleramt sie will dass das
Ding zu ihr kommt in ihr Ministerium und
das könnte am Ende dazu führen dass gar
kein Sicherheitsrat kommt nach dem Motto
wenn ich Dir nicht Krieg kriegst du auch
nicht kommt das wirklich so was wird das
für unsere Sicherheit heißen und vor
allem woran liegt das dass das
Verhältnis von Kanzler und
Außenministerin so belastet ist genau
darauf wollen wir heute schauen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ist meine lieblingsfrage genau
beziehungsweise wo kam es the beef her
Klammer auf alle die sich mit
Jugendsprache nicht so auskennen wie
unser Kanzler wie kommt aus dem Hip Hop
und bedeutet sowas wie aggressive
Auseinandersetzung Klammer zu also wie
ist das persönliche Verhältnis der
beiden ich verspreche euch in paar
Minuten der selbst eine ziemlich genaue
Vorstellung davon wo das Verhältnis der
beiden zu verordnen ist auf einer Skala
von ich sag mal nicht so gern haben bis
Liebe kleiner Hinweis selbst die
Regierungssprecherin ist eher
zurückhaltend
von Liebe sprechen nein
aber sagt sie wir arbeiten in der
Bundesregierung eng und vertrauensvoll
zusammen und sie wissen ja dass es eine
Richtlinienkompetenz des Kanzlers gibt
aber an die muss in diesem Zusammenhang
im Grunde gar nicht erinnert werden
nein gezeichnet das ist trotzdem tut wie
fest alles in der Politik hat das ganze
natürlich eine Vorgeschichte im letzten
Bundestagswahlkampf haben die beiden ja
noch direkt konkurriert wollten beide
ins Kanzleramt und wollen das auch
weiterhin ne ist zwar noch ein bisschen
hin bis zur nächsten Bundestagswahl 20
25 aber das muss man immer im Hinterkopf
behalten ja haben die beiden da könnt
ihr euch sicher sein auch ja egal wir
harmonisch ihr Verhältnis zwischendurch
aussah und das sicher phasenweise auch
war sie sind und bleiben auch immer
Wettbewerber darf man nicht vergessen
klar sie müsste erstmal wieder
Kandidatin werden für die Grünen gegen
Robert Habeck darüber wird wohl nur weil
entscheiden irgendwann aber dass sie
einen neuen Anlauf aufs Kanzleramt
nehmen will und das ist für unsere
Analyse entscheidend daran gibt es wenig
Zweifel bei den Grünen so bevor ihr
jetzt sagen boah die Medien ja ihr guckt
wieder nur auf personality Stories gar
nicht auf die Sache da sage ich das ist
Teil der Sache ja weil wenn die eine
Person der anderen nur bedingt
politische Erfolge gönnt weil das Berlin
oder sie irgendwann im nächsten
Wahlkampf nachteilig sein könnte dann
kann das durchaus ganz effektiv Politik
beeinflussen und damit die Sache und
dass das hier genauso ist das meine ich
doch ziemlich deutlich rausgehört zu
haben aus diversen Gesprächen sowohl mit
Leuten aus dem Kanzleramt als auch mit
Leuten aus bärbox Ministerium dem
Auswärtigen Amt das also erstmal die
Ausgangssituation zweiter Faktor das
Naturell könnte bei beiden wohl kaum
weiter auseinander liegen Scholz
nordisch kühl abwarten sie emotional
spontan besonders deutlich werden diese
Unterschiede in der Kommunikation die
eine sehr wichtige Rolle spielt in der
Politik ja er rhetorisch ja wie
beschreiben was am besten oberflächlich
könnte man sagen langweilig aber ganz
sicher kein Zufall man kann glaube ich
ziemlich sicher davon ausgehen dass
Scholz ganz bewusst so redet weil das
für ihn einen großen Vorteil bringt das
gesagt er lässt sich im Nachhinein fast
nie gegen ihn verwenden weil vieles eben
in nebulös bleibt lange Sätze wenig
Botschaft sie Annalena Werbung dagegen
gesagt manchmal selbst in sehr kurzen
Sätzen mehr als sie eigentlich sagen
will we are fighting against Russia and
not against each other
ihr mindest ganz fix klarstellen müssen
dass das so eigentlich gar nicht gemeint
war und diese wie auch immer man es
nennen will Flapsigkeit fehlende
Vorsicht manche sagen sprachliche
Streubreite die ist natürlich nicht ganz
irrelevant bei einer Außenministerin
oder wie mein Kollege vom Spiegel
gefüttert hat schon einigermaßen
unfassbar dass die Außenministerin deren
fast einziger Job es ist Worte auf die
Goldwaage zu legen so ein Ding raushaut
ja
es gibt allerdings was was ihn Olaf
Scholz nach allem was man so hört noch
weitaus mehr ärgert als solche ich nenne
es mal verbalen Missgeschicke und zwar
Belehrung ja und die gab es schon
mehrmals von Werbung Beispiel Umgang mit
China da ist Scholz hingereist kurz
nachdem Ping seine Macht zementiert
hatte bei diesem ziemlich verstörenden
Parteitag letzten Herbst vielleicht
könnte ich erinnern Scholz war dann
erster westlicher Gratulant daran gab es
viel Kritik die meist beachtete von ihr
ja damals sogar ganz ungewöhnlich von
der Dienstreise aus aus dem Ausland aus
Usbekistan da sagte sie erstmal diesen
Satz hier der Bundeskanzler hat den
Zeitpunkt seiner Reise entschieden wenn
ich das mal kurz übersetzen darf ja aus
dem diplomatischen ins Deutsche dann
heißt das ungefähr so viel wie also ich
finde den Zeitpunkt aber mal so richtig
schlecht ja und dann hat sie ihm auch
noch gesagt was er denn dann bitte tun
mögen nämlich das hier und jetzt ist
entscheidend die Botschaften die wir
gemeinsam festgelegt haben im
Koalitionsvertrag auch in China deutlich
zu machen dass die Frage von fairen
Wettbewerbsbedingungen dass die Frage
von Menschenrechten
Arbeitsauftrag für den eigenen Chef
sozusagen
ungefähr vorstellen wie dankbar der so
ein Auftrag zur Kenntnis nimmt
so gab es im Laufe des letzten Jahres
seit dem Start der Ampel immer wieder
mal kleinere und mittlere ich nenne es
mal kommunikative Zusammenstöße jetzt
nicht die Zeit die alle aufzuzählen nur
den letzten noch mal im Januar in Paris
da war habt ihr vielleicht mitbekommen
das komplette Bundeskabinett hin gereist
wegen 60 Jahre Aussöhnung Frankreich
Deutschland nach dem Krieg ich war auch
mit dabei im regierungsflieger hat der
ja auch so die Atmosphäre mitbekommen
die Stimmung so ein bisschen aufnehmen
können und da hat Scholz am Abend bei
einer Pressekonferenz noch die Zusage
explizit verweigert dass man anderen
Ländern erlaubt die Ukraine mit
Kampfpanzern auszustatten ja und fast
zeitgleich quasi ein paar Meter weiter
im französischen Fernsehen hat sie
gesagt doch doch also wir werden nicht
blockieren wenn andere Länder liefern
wollen wir werden sie nicht hindern
sogenannten paar Stunden später war dann
der Rückflug ich war wieder mit dabei
Anna-Lena baerbock nicht die ist nach
Brüssel weiter gereist und in der
Kanzlermaschine da gab es dann kurz nach
dem Abheben so gegen Mitternacht noch
mal ein sogenanntes Hintergrundgespräch
mit dem Kanzler vorne hinterm Cockpit in
so einem in so einer kleinen Kabine mit
schicken Sofas haben sich dann so ca 20
Leute reingequetscht auf Gefühl 10
Quadratmetern sehr gute Luft ja und
Regel ist dass wir Journalisten nicht
veröffentlichen was Politiker bei
solchen Hintergrundgesprächen erzählen
dafür sind sie dann in der Regel so ein
bisschen offener und diese Regel halte
ich mich natürlich auch ich sagte er
jetzt nicht wie Scholz Bär Box Aussagen
kommentiert hat nur so viel dass seine
Laune trotzdem gut war lag eine
Vermutung ihr an dem guten Abend essen
damit Wein Begleitung dass er zuvor mit
immer nur im macron hatte er als an den
Aussagen der Außenministerin Aussagen
die medial in Deutschland deine
ziemliche Welle gemacht haben hier
Schlagzeilen
und interessant war dass bärbock in dem
Interview noch was anderes gesagt hat
was in Deutschland ziemlich unbeachtet
blieb weil die Nachrichtenagenturen das
nicht übersetzt haben nämlich dies hier
jetzt sei nicht der Moment wo man mit
dem Finger auf andere zeige sondern
gemeinsam müsste man nun alles tun damit
die Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnt damit
die Ukraine gewinnt ja einen Satz den
Scholz da schon fast ein Jahr lang ganz
konsequent verweigert hat und das
natürlich schon ein Problem wenn Kanzler
und Außenministerin bei so einer
zentralen Frage unterschiedliches sagen
zumal es eben nicht nur da ist die Zeit
hat kürzlich rekonstruiert welche
unterschiedliche Signale Scholz und
bärbock in der panzerfrage über Monate
hinweg an die westlichen Partner
gesendet haben ähnlich eben wie in Paris
und da sagt dann nicht nur die
Opposition die allerdings besonders oft
das schwächt Deutschland ja und auch da
könnt ihr euch sicher selbst ausrechnen
wie das bei ihm ja ankommt wenn es ja
noch so eine Art gefühlte kuhkanzlerin
neben ihm gibt aber einem der nicht nur
immer betont dass er so handelt und
entscheidet immer
besorgen sondern der auch immer
durchblicken lässt dass er die richtig
wichtigen Entscheidungen ganz oben also
auf alle oberster Ebene bespricht zum
Beispiel mit seinem Freund Joe Biden im
self also dass er in der Liga unterwegs
ist nicht Chefetage sondern
chefcheffetage das führt uns nun zu
unserer Eingangsfrage bekommen wir hier
in Deutschland auch so ein Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat wie der Joe den in seinem
weißen Haushalt die Überlegung gibt es
ganz konkret als Teil einer nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie das ist ein
Dokument derzeit den Arbeit streng
geheim so ca 40 Seiten je nachdem wie es
formatiert ist und da arbeiten mehrere
Ministerien dran alle die was mit
Sicherheit zu tun haben Verteidigung
außen Kanzleramt Wirtschaftsministerium
und so weiter die Federführung hat ihren
Ministerium das Auswärtige Amt und da
gab es den Wunsch fertig zu werden mit
dieser Strategie bis zur Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz mit februar um da
dann der Welt zu zeigen sieht her wir
haben verstanden russische Angriffskrieg
neue Weltlage das hier ist jetzt unser
vegan unser Konzept so wollen wir mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen während
ziemlich gute Bilder für Annalena
baerbock das war die Idee aber dann ging
es kurz vor Weihnachten auf einmal nicht
mehr weiter ja nachdem man bis dahin
eigentlich ziemlich gut vorangekommen
war es gab ein paar Schritte gepunkte
das schon aber sagen wir Insider nichts
was man bei gutem Willen ich hätte lösen
können ja die beteiligten Ministerien
waren da auf der sogenannten
Arbeitsebene unterwegs und dann wird das
plötzlich auf eine höhere Ebene gezogen
waren dann unter dem Staatssekretäre
beteiligt mit dem Ergebnis dass ich
seitdem vieles verzögert ob das nun
bewusst so geschehen ist damit wer Bock
nicht glänzen kann was manche vermuten
man weiß es nicht fakt ist aber dieses
angedachte neue Gremium der sogenannte
nationale Sicherheitsrat der kommt nun
zumindest bis auf weiteres erstmal nicht
fun fact dazu
nationaler Sicherheitsrat soll er wohl
ohnehin nicht heißen weil
aminaschitz genau so einen Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat wortwörtlich gefordert
hatte
dem Wahlkampf gegen die beiden erinnert
euch und das finden manche wird jetzt
nicht so cool kommen wenn es aussehe als
wird man dessen Ideen nun umsetzen der
gar nicht so fun fact ist jetzt aber
vielleicht kommt am Ende gar kein
solches Gremium weil man uneins ist wo
das anzusiedeln wäre ja Schulz SPD
findet im Kanzleramt wer Box grüne
finden in ihrem Ministerium ja auch wenn
mir das die beiden Parteivorsitzenden im
Interview im Bundestag nicht so deutlich
in die Kamera sagen wollten es
stattdessen so umschrieben haben meine
persönliche Erfahrung der letzten Jahre
war dass ihr Höhe die
Absprache aufgehängt worden ist das so
abstrakter wurde das es ist aber
notwendig dass man so kriegt konkret wie
möglich wird vor allem es ist ein
Querschnittsthema und deswegen ist es
richtig dass so ein Gremium und das
insgesamt die Debatte auch ganz zentral
in der Bundesregierung angesiedelt ist
also
aus dem Kanzleramt hört man gut wenn wir
uns jetzt nicht einigen können dann
kommt halt nichts Neues ja dann wird es
bei den wichtigen sicherheitspolitischen
Fragen also entschieden wie bisher
nämlich im Zweifel in ziemlich kleinem
Kreis und Kanzleramt muss nicht so
kommen aber könnte ja wenn man sich
nicht doch noch irgendwie einigt wie
auch bei ein paar anderen strittigen
Punkten bei dieser Sicherheitsstrategie
z.B Rüstungsausgaben Katastrophenschutz
und so weiter führt uns nun zur
erwähnten Anschlussfrage beeinträchtigt
dass Deutschland Sicherheit mit Blick
auf den Nationalen Sicherheitsrat der
nicht nationaler Sicherheitsrat heißen
würde das sagen viele Fachleute wer
schon sinnvoll so ein Gremium zu haben
er grad in akuten Krisensituation man
könnte dann schnell zusammenkommen gelbe
klare Zuständigkeiten andererseits
selbst dann bliebe es am Ende natürlich
bei der Richtlinienkompetenz des Kanzler
das heißt am Ende hat er den Hut auf und
entscheidet wenn er denn entscheidet
dieses Zögern und zaubern wie seine
Kritiker sagen bzw diese Besonderheit
für die erst nennt das würde zumindest
solange er Kanzler ist bleiben ja ob man
jetzt ein Nationalen Sicherheitsrat der
nicht nationaler Sicherheitsrat heißen
würde hat oder nicht vielleicht noch
wichtiger ist allerdings dass das die
grundsätzliche Problematik zeigt wenn
man sich schon bei den Strukturen nicht
einigen kann wie will man sich dann in
der Sache auf eine gemeinsame
Außenpolitik einigen zumal diese
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
eigentlich nur der Anfang sein sollte
darüber hinaus soll es zusätzlich
nämlich noch eine sogenannte China
Strategie geben mit der sich die
Bundesregierung dann Leitplanken geben
will für den künftigen Umgang mit China
aber wie uneinig man sich da ist habe
ich ja eben schon mal angedeutet bottom
line von der Außenpolitik aus einem Guss
ja die wortwörtlich im Koalitionsvertrag
in Aussicht gestellt war von der ist
derzeit doch ziemlich wenig zu spüren
und das zeigt auch egal wer dann in ein
paar Jahren bei den Grünen fürs
Kanzleramt kandidieren wird die Spannung
dieses Konkurrenzdenken das wird
mutmaßlich weniger werden es sei denn es
gibt da noch eine verborgene Seite im
Kanzler die keiner kennt sondern
ausgelassenen karnevalsjäck Anna-Lena
baerbrock hat nämlich kürzlich bei der
manche sagen weltbesten
Karnevalsveranstaltungen wieder den
tierischen Ernst im wunderbaren Aachen
sich so ein bisschen über den Kanzler
lustig gemacht über das sich Zeit lassen
bei Entscheidungen sie sagte sie sei vor
ihrer Rede extra gewarnt worden keine
Witze über den Kanzler zu machen und
Achtung selbst Ironie keine Versprecher
zu machen jetzt die Pointe keine
Versprecher macht man ja eigentlich nur
wenn man gar nichts sagt
das können andere besser
ich bin sicher auch der Kanzler fand das
total komisch insofern in dreifach
kräftiges Woche
inside politics
Außenpolitik aus einem Guss
[Musik]